non è possibile non è possibile non è
possibile christian a tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovo video sono fa
vigente oggi biden aveva fatto un gioco
del genere tanto tempo fa che si
chiamava hai un abito e guy avevamo
fatto due episodi ragazzi su iphone
avide ghiaia non l'avevo più continuato
e ci sarà un motivo vero ragazzi che
fosse in assoluto il gioco più difficile
che io abbia mai fatto in tutta la mia
vita quindi
ma è così madonna che mi carica che non
avete idea place select 63 tipo super
mario vado sui livelli
si ok testa questa qua ragazzi è solo la
scelta del livello cioè non è neanche
livello porta [ __ ] ciapa jafar due
match 22 metri due metri
se sì allora porca di quella [ __ ]
[ __ ] laida devi morire ma cosa ma cosa
vuoi da mia vita figlia sono ripartito
di quattro i bardi perfetto press fire a
ho cliccato cose va bene siamo partiti
ragazzi è già un bordello così anche
bello e grafica tipo metal gear solid
che faccio
l'atterraggio più bello che abbia mai
visto in tutta la mia vita complimenti a
una pid e minchia posso saltare mentre
sono sul paracadute dichiara la fisica
mille rega ce l'ho fatta ho detto stai
dicendo che posso prendere il monte
everest e cliccarlo su per il culo a tua
madre piano pian piano no no a semi
succhiami le minchia 2 tutte e due
ok non cade più perfetto che facciano
gli item i ragazzi che un checkpoint vi
prego perché se non posso morire
ok no no no e no
e c'è scritto save l'asi stronzo dovevo
prendere su sono io [ __ ] per questo
lo sapevo adesso ciò checkpoint quindi
botte sega perfetto il curati tutti
posso sparare assomiglia di pesce per
favore grazie non non è morto ma se
volete qua ok
stavo scherzando realtà voce zanda
conosci la parola scherzo zio
ecco è esattamente quello che stavo
facendo allora ci sarà un modo per far
sta merda bellissima è anche caduto il
microfono
dobbiamo chiarirci perché non posso
vivere così cosa ho fatto
oddio ok con le medaglie subito che
cazzo è sta roba
chi è quello ragazzi cè un power ranger
fermi troppo non ci sono solo fatto
molto e bene che mi serve ansa salgo su
senti power ranger vista minchia regista
al card si no no non ci sono arrivato a
tanto così madonna al tuo pene per di
tutti i fermi tutti morire si si è
ucciso no ce la posso fare
se dio non è possibile
c'era il salvataggio di salvataggio
modon c'è la cosa stupenda che io lo
sapevo a cosa andavo incontro e pure
hanno fatto uguale bene li facciamo
ma perché non sapevo cazzo che ti
attacchi dai che ti attacchi ma dovete
attacchi arc azoth attacchi e mezz'ora
che prova a fare solo questo morite
bastardi sì io sono fermi perché non ci
credo non ci credo ci ho fatto a fare un
check point impossibile nella vita però
soste cosi ma basta ancora
non ha idea di che cosa siano ma non me
ne frega niente per mandare avanti lo
stesso non ce la farò mai culo roba
impossibile sì o il cazzo di beffi
makhateli merde ogni tetto quando
pensavo di avercela fatta crepe o non sa
o si odia chi cazzo sei tu muori non so
chi sei ma devi creare perfetto beh la
cosa triste che non lo rifarò mai più in
tutta la mia vita ma il più quindi ce lo
ha fatto stavolta grazie al mister
grazie mille ogni tanto ragazzi
completamente a chi accusa c'è donkey
kong che lancia degli barili fermina ti
fermi un secondo o vabbè vabbè vabbè
pollici in su a manetta cosa riuscito
non so come a prendere un checkpoint va
bene così non mi faccia altre domande va
bene così non so per quale il culo di li
sto dicendo non so per quale culo di
meno sia riuscita a fa sta roba ma non
riuscirà mai più tutta la vita ok ma al
barile si chiama pietro e torna indietro
ma [ __ ] pietro tutti pietro che
stanno ascoltando questo video non ce
l'ho con voi ce l'ho col barile del
cazzo avete presente il detto che nella
botte piccola c'è il vino buono eccolo
nella botte c'è tua madre tua madre che
gira dai dai dai dai dai dai dai crepa
ok ci si è fatta già fatta cielo mano
sono morto bene bene bene
perfetto l'importante è che ho capito ho
capito mesi fa aspettando il secondo e
poi salta macello se non ce la farò mai
più nella vita forse invece si è invece
si è invece la propaggine al sopravvento
puntante tua madre però ce l'ha con te
ne vai una b day by ke since c'è quello
è il problema di sto bambino della
minkia se già fatta per me no cosa devo
fare va bene possibile composto mai
nella vita
porca [ __ ] vi supplico di su
si ok ok come faccio qui in poi arrivano
i barili precisamente cosa dovevo andare
come fare
non posso ho capito ok madonna madonna
madonna si cancellò anche che cazzo di
cosa minchia ti lanci barili comunque le
tette che ti ritrovi mi faccia bar me lo
spiegate non vi prego perché non ce la
farò mai più seno che per noi è certo
per in basso no oddio come fatta forza
nuova famiglia di scasso la famiglia
così ma non riesco a saltare per non
riesco a salta cazzo si o dio ma
[ __ ] lo presti non preso davvero
oh mio dio si è incazzato pro ok sto
scherzando scherzando mi chiami sapremo
mista marco pannella non ce la farò mai
ragazzi sì l'ho preso si crea che mila
di merda dai dai dai lancia cos'è ma
questi bug dai cani nota la della
[ __ ] porca ma come come la torta di
me ma mica tanto un coltello mi serve
nella torta per capire dire è grave
questa cosa però non c'è ma come fanno
il bello e che è il pri il primo livello
il primo il primo di merda il primo ci
sono 326 contam in quanto dura sto gioco
call calmo bravo lancia al barile bravo
prendi il barile che cade bravo pian
piano piano piano gesù piano ok ma non
ho capito niente della vita non ho
capito una minchia alla questo sono
infine bullock è un no no no c'era
l'altro che che miscela l'altro ragazzi
voi siete consapevoli che non finirò mai
questo gioco verona ve lo dico perché
non sono lo sapete ve lo dico io e come
facciamo a impossibile
come dovrei fare non è un posto cesar
tomoyo sono stato mai allora sei strambo
ce l'ha fatta a fermi tutti cos'è cazzo
se va bene un paio di altri sette
avanzano se vuoi e seta vanza non è il
bello è che se voi adesso minori far
tutto non ci arriverò mai più qua
figuriamoci pc da provare
sì no no no no no no
mi sento affranto da sui giochi non è
possibile non è possibile non è
possibile christian ma come fai a far ma
metto in un cazzo di check point su tre
ore che sono solo qui ma minchia sono
dodici anni di gioco malizioso ma
[ __ ] ragazzi come li prendi me lo
chiedo in ginocchio come minchia li
prendo sti barili
porca trottola no quasi si può dire
oddio oddio fermi fermi tutti
mi sono ammazzato da solo l'ho fatta ok
mi muovo di nuovo di moio sì sì l'ho
preso oddio oddio oddio oddio o mio dio
mio dio mio dio
[Musica]
cazzo cazzo capra capra unicorno non
l'ho mai tra dispiace che ho lanciato
dall euforia va bene non mi fa non ho
capito manco io cosa va bene così di
calcio il cuore che sta uscendo dalla
finestra va bene così ragazzi va bè
ragazzi credo che continuerò nel
prossimo episodio ad andare avanti
perché sono sto qua tutto il giorno ed è
una roba indecente
spero che vi sia piaciuto nel primo
episodio sono contento di farne un altro
non vedo adesso da domani inizia a
contare i giorni che non vedo l'ora di
fare il secondo episodio giuro credete
impero che questo sia valso mi piace
perché l'unicorno vuole mi piace è vero
che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cose
conseguito è piaciuta lasciando quanto
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook e
come hai vissuto la prescrizione se
avessi discrete ci vediamo al prossimo
vinto bel regalo